quoi de l'agent l'on retourné sur la
portée de la jambe qui croisait pour
caroline ils sont tous des champions ils
ont accepté le défi de bouger le but
remettre ses ex itinérant en mouvement
dans tous les sens du terme se préparer
pour la cause pour michel dominique et
les autres c'est un moment de solidarité
pour briser la solitude c'est un
engagement un pas de plus en route vers
l'autonomie et si à force de résilience
et de volonté il chemine vers une forme
d' équilibre leur parcours est aussi
parsemé de chutes et de rechute
j'ai des preuves d'un sentimental puis
je suis beaucoup de stress car l'accord
puis aussi on a découvert que j'avais un
petit peu de schizophrénie fait des
hallucinations et j'entends des voix
mais avec la médication et l'osce a
appris quelques années à main quand on a
eu la bonne dose ça ça n'existe plus
qu'il a dans la fosse du dédale ça a
duré sept mois
puis je pouvais pas prendre mes
médicaments parce que j'ai dans rue puis
sa cause la somnolence l'ex est
dangereux c'est pour une femme c'est
dangereux des dans la rue tout seul car
c'est dans reach d'impôts donc j'étais
rendu à 80 lignes c'est pas de bruits
oui je t'assure bord de mourir j'allais
mourir puis je prenais pas un médicament
a fait que de plus à l'aise plus j'étais
folle j'ai fait une tentative de suicide
ratée aux buttes ou fait c'est plus un
appel à la haine
je tape pas c'était quand même trop lent
trop son appel à l'aide a été entendu
entre autres par l'organisme
communautaire le sac à dos ou marie
josée ce que maintenant de l'accueil au
centre de jour avec son expérience de la
vue elle est bien placé pour comprendre
les besoins
il faut s'informer auprès de l'ecc asie
postale casier postal c'est un service
essentiel pour un sans domicile fixe
avec cette adresse il est possible de
recevoir par exemple un chèque ou encore
on peut aussi bénéficier d'un espace de
rangement
vous allez manger joue bien c'est quoi
ton numéro jeanneret attirant non michel
legault possédait un casier
ça veut dire ne pas traîner toutes ses
possessions pas mal plus facile pour les
déplacements mais l'aide la plus
importante pour ceux qui acceptent de
s'inscrire dans un programme de
réinsertion c'est la possibilité
d'obtenir un studio donc un toit une
adresse le logement comme sahbi c6
hameaux comme ok ça a été comme dire si
repose toi et tes par proust oui et puis
en plus jusqu'à pas de manger si je tape
pas de manger des bonnes affaires
pas juste des noms bien pleine et 9 h
les deux jours avec une patate c'est là
j'ai commencé à vraiment penser à qui
j'ai des rails j'aimerais aller réaliser
j'aimerais se retourner travailler
j'aimerais ça comme un citoyen comme les
autres et la citoyenne marie-josée
trouve important de prendre part à
l'événement courir pour sortir de la rue
elle sait très bien que l'aide les
mettant du ont été essentiels pour
qu'elle puisse survivre
voici pourquoi elle aimerait que les
coureurs soient vraiment nombreux sur la
ligne de départ c'est correct on sent
bien qu'on donne deux piasses au bord
mais les deux pièces il repart loin ses
six pollock faut le net c'est dans les
logements sociaux ou ce que ou ce qui va
vraiment voir un changement dans la vie
de la personne
ici on est en sécurité puis on est aidé
fait que je pense que de court et la
course
c'est un pauvre vraiment
les choses pour juste place
c'est vraiment créer quelque chose qui
va durer longtemps qu'il voyait dépérir